Wow do I have a treat for you guys today. I'm
holding an original guitar that's over 180 years
old. This beautiful instrument, which was likely
made in the 1840s, was made by Salvador Ramirez
in Malaga, Spain. You can see it's had quite the
life and that it has had many cracks restored. You
can see it looks quite old but still plays thanks
to a lot of people doing restorations including
Richard Brune whose shop I'm at now. I'm here with
Marshall and Richard and they've been kind enough
to brief me about this beautiful instrument. In
fact, I'm very lucky because today I'm actually
recording on this instrument and those recordings
will be part of an exhibit at the National Museum
in South Dakota. It is so beautiful to
look at and actually the sound is amazing.
Like a lot of 19th century guitars at the
time this instrument is smaller and it
has quite a mellow sound. It doesn't
have this sort of canon effect that
modern guitars often go for (modern
classical guitars that is). They're
going for volume. This is really not about
volume. I think it's about charm personally.
he sound is warm and mellow and beautiful. On
the body you see this amazing floral design here.
Apparently this was done actually to cover up an
accident that the guitar had at some point in its
long life this patch of wood here apparently is
not original it was replaced on the sound board
this whole thing is a different piece of wood
than the rest of the of the top and apparently
when this was was done they then put on this
beautiful floral decided to sort of cover it
up. The top itself is likely spruce or fur. The
back is made of Brazilian rosewood which is an
exotic rare wood and then the strip here is this
beautiful Bird's Eye Maple a common wood for backs
in the 19th century. Up here at the headstock
things get a little crazy we have number one
pegs which is characteristic of early 19th century
guitars these friction pegs you just push in and
turn just like violins or cellos was used on
lutes and Baroque guitars. It's actually very
common and they work quite well when made well at
both ends there's a cap of ivory the actual design
line of the of the headstock here is sort of
a scroll effect which I have never seen before
of course I'm using gut strings which is the
strings that would have been on the instrument
at the time in fact before 1940 almost all
guitars would have had gut strings and that of
course is intestine, usually sheep intestine.
It's actually a fantastic sound. Super warm,
mellow and you can feel the texture on the on
the strings. If you don't know about gut strings,
you can watch my video all about it here.
Let's listen to a recording I made of a
full piece for this exhibition
this is Tarrega's famous Lágrima.
That is such a simple piece but it's so beautiful and charming and
I think it really works with the mellow tone
of this instrument. Now the bridge is actually
really interesting. It also has a bit of ivory
on it some inlays here just for beautiful
decoration and then the strings take a weird
path they actually go around the bridge here
going through the back end then they pop out
the the bridge side underneath the strings which
I've never seen before. Richard was telling me
that that's common for some Italian guitars
he's seen on the inside of the instrument it's
like sort of fascinating world there's all these
cleats which are these wooden patches to sort of
fix a crack and so there's really a whole history
in here of different restoration attempts by
different luthiers. Now the instrument is smaller
than we're used to 19th century guitars in general
in the early 19th century were were a bit
smaller and that's part of the reason they have
the characteristic sound that they do this one
has a surprisingly good bass range for the size.
So I'd highly recommend a visit to the National
Museum in South Dakota it's an amazing Museum
filled with lutes, Baroque guitars and many other
amazing instruments and if you go at the right
time you might find this instrument with my video
playing next to it. Thanks so much for watching
if you like this video please do subscribe. My
analytics tell me that 70% of you who watch my
videos aren't subscribed, so if you want to help
the channel grow please do like and subscribe
and you'll see my weekly updates. And before we
go I want to thank Richard Brune for his great
work on this instrument and also recommended me to
record these pieces for the national museum. Also,
if you're interested in classical guitar I
have an online course which is six hours long
it's a beginner course it is meant to take
people along their first about six months
of learning the classical guitar and I've
heard from so many of the students who've
taken it so far they seem to really love it
and can't wait for the intermediate course,
which hopefully will be out very soon. So
please check out the link in the description
for Classical Guitar Pro. Until next
time, thank you guys for watching!